yeah it's not working I should be Justin
Timberlake Doug looks like Hillary
Clinton five and today we are recreating
iconic boy band outs and covers
NSYNC Backstreet Boys and out one
direction all these boy bands have five
peoples but we only have four try guys
Ned is bringing in his college friend
Doug as long as he knows that I'm the
star and he's not expecting to be the
Timberlake haha I love him we get an
outside personality and try guys videos
because you never know what happens one
of if try guy is added this is the best
day ever
I love dogs so much as long as I got to
be JT I'm gonna be fine that's not okay
I'm Keith of the try guys
aka Justin Timberlake of NSYNC he's
falling asleep he's here you I've heard
a lot about you from Ned and they're
really really excited to have you on the
shoot so are you worried that he's gonna
be the new small one I'm the cute furry
small one and now we got another cute
first moment why do we why do we need
done it just doesn't make sense to me
you know when your college friends meet
your try guy friends kind of worried
that everyone's gonna get along but
seems like everyone's getting along
great hey Chuck
hi mm-hmm you read do this Doug will he
even got the sexy eyes down
that's sexy gaze there are so many soul
patches and but cuts on this album cover
it makes me kind of thing what's a butt
cut what keith has on his head
no I haven't looked at it yet because I
don't want to look at it you look like a
like an evil scientist my wife said I
looked Italian these white clothes are
pretty awesome is that pretty yeah I
feel like people don't have the
confidence to rock just I'll weigh on an
album cover
more here's the thing Doug if you're
gonna be the leader you have to stand up
targets being really hard to work with I
don't really want to talk about Doug is
repeatedly undercutting me taking all
the cutest members of the band and
making me the worst one that no one
wants to be honestly Doug is the best
person ever worked with it's great to
strive for excellence next to an expert
okay Doug so we just did the Backstreet
Boys millennium album cover now it's
time to move on to our favorite band
insane and obviously since you got to be
the leader of that and you did a
terrible job it's my turn now to beat
Joey fat one he's looking at us real
weird I just wanna say Doug that I
noticed that you've pushed me further to
the outside in this photo I don't
appreciate it Raman hair we always
wanted to be in sync because we all
wanted to be Justin and now look at this
guy
I love NSYNC when I was a kid I watched
like a documentary on NSYNC on the
Disney Channel boy bands were for girls
and his dad you were supposed to not
like my sister got the Darren's dance
through DVD and I tried to learn this
dance it is the hardest [ __ ] thing
I've ever done
Oh most beautiful beautiful buzzy member
you know there was some tension there
earlier but I think Keith and Doug are
really appreciating each other
professionally hey Doug can I talk to
you for a second look I know you and I
have had our differences today but this
last photo shoot I think it's really
important that everyone just end the day
happy what do you say we just for this
last shoot bury the hatchet and let all
of us choose our own one direction
member thanks Doug
he becomes stylist Lee Haeri
what is here looks like here we are good
one direction Doug thanks again for
letting us pick our members this time I
think you kind of I think it's a nice
way to end the guys deck really one
direction is the NSYNC and Backstreet
Boys of the young generation basketball
isn't in sync there's always kind of
like a few not so cute members but
across the board one Direction's pretty
good luck everyone in here One Direction
oh the thing about this album cover it
almost looks like it's just like an
Instagram photo yeah comics like a photo
booth yeah yeah just five rows hanging
out probably took them five hours to do
just like this one
Doug you're the expert we trust you what
should we do for this picture good then
man
all right through it and yeah holding
those poses without moving was really
really hard it was really tough
introducing my old friend Doug to the
try guys but I think everyone bonded
together at the end you know Doug does
he brings people together
and I'm gonna share being the small cute
hairy one with anyone glad and Doug
although we weren't friends in the
beginning now we're totally best friends
forever and I'm just really glad for the
opportunity we had to share with him
it's been a pretty good day
well thank you so much for showing this
in ways Doug I know we had our
differences throughout the day but now
we're ready to offer you a permanent
position with the try guy what do you
say pal yeah we don't need him you know
guys I have a confession to make he's
not actually my college roommate he's
just a dog